papou la chanson la danse la musique les
instruments le côté un peu festif le
côté un peu pleuré le côté le côté la
famille - le mans les gars c'est un
façon de s'exprimer
les amuser de discuter maloya bdp qui
s'y met tu écoutes dans le temps dans la
fête et a vu aussi les papas jamais
roulé en avait 6 ans alors ma commotion
au sol après m'appartient peu l'écho la
musique
vesely d'orsay c'est un affidé ma canne
ou des autres pays c'est miss corse
le maloya est avec le séga l'un des deux
genres musicaux majeurs de la réunion le
terme maloya a plusieurs significations
suivant les dialectes de l'afrique de
l'est au mozambique maloya signifie
incantations sorcellerie au zimbabwe
grand sorcier en bambara honte et à
madagascar maloya au veut dire parler
des gouazé dire ce que l'on a à dire
dans de nombreux dialectes africains il
signifierait tél d'où leur mal être
longtemps interdit à la réunion le
maloya est classé au patrimoine culturel
immatériel de l'humanité de l'unesco
depuis le 1er octobre 2009
nous sommes dans le quartier des
camélias sur cet espace au pied des
immeubles le groupe fanal au caire se
réunit pour une répétition
nadège leader du groupe nous raconte ses
débuts avec le maloya ma commence avec
les tontons danseuse folklorique et
cauris ensuite ma rencontre christine
salem grâce à mon ton temps ne l'a
commencé à chanter ensemble et là le
groupe salem tradition l'a été montée et
donc mal inconnu
les tournées pendant une dizaine
d'années tous qui dit les grandes scènes
ici en fin de compte et ensuite ma
décide d'arrêter de faire un break de
remettre un peu en question et 2
présentement les bonnes questions aussi
sur le maloya et des questions la jeune
femme sont déposés avant de revenir au
maloya faire du maloya pourquoi pour qui
mais aussi comment si malade décide de
fait du maloya aujourd'hui c'est pour
montanes ouverture montre un autre côté
du maloya aussi parce que les vrais
hommes dans cet été esclaves que men à
la danse le chant et n'a l'appel aux
esprits mais pour moi on dirait que tout
ça c'est me dis pas c'est notre monnaie
mais c'est un côté et ici en fin de
compte cette nous vivent tous les jours
bien oublié nous n'oublions nous dans
cette nous fait nous pense que nous en
cet esclave mais nous oblige aujourd'hui
ne continuerais est esclave et nous
continuerons moment remémore à nous ça
tous les ans et de dire nous que ben
nous fait pitié que la ville et du que
nenê le mal être que tout cela et nous
obligent la ville et gaillard que nenê
le bonheur que naît dans l'amour que na
plein de choses que nous nena et que
nous donne pas la place à tout ça est
dans cet esprit d'évolution vers un
maloya plus moderne
nadège et son groupe laisse justement de
la place avec notamment l'ajout d'autres
instruments que ceux utilisés
traditionnellement
on n'avait pas compris vous permettez un
flûte ou bien basse immigrés violon ou
un autre instrument pour dit que maloya
la besoin aussi d'évoluer deux roues
vallier aussi et d'art est résident dans
cette ombre là dans ce cercle fermé lun
et vouloir vraiment fait sans talent et
de cet esclavage
mais